all right last night right here on this
program we did something you don't often
see from so-called journalists yeah we
actually broke news
now our lengthy interview with Rudy
Giuliani covered a wide range of topics
it unearth a lot of important insight
into the Trump legal team including this
moment when the former New York City
Mayor now president Trump's attorney
Rudy Giuliani called out Robert Muller's
pathetic witch-hunt take a look the
president's right when he says
witch-hunt yeah sure you can't explain
this any other way
first of all they never should have been
investigation there was no Russian
collusion we're now a year and a half
two years into this no Russian collusion
case over in falling all over themselves
to investigate him they have committed
numerous violations
now Giuliani did not stop there he also
slammed the special councilors questions
to president Trump you know the ones
recently leaked to the fake news New
York Times take a look at this when you
look at those questions about what does
the president think what does the
president feel what does the president
really desire those are all questions
intended to trap him in some way in
contradictory what is in fact a very
very solid explanation of what happened
now the former mayor is absolutely right
and breaking tonight while robert muller
sets a perjury trap for president trump
the special counsel has filed a request
for seventy blank subpoenas in the case
of Paul Manafort in other words Muller
now has the power to subpoena dozens of
Americans so long as he writes that name
on the paper before he serves the
documents Wow this is interesting well
analyze all of that what is seemingly an
aggressive legal tactic and one that we
would expect from him but first more
news from I sit down with the former
mayor including these comments that he
made the media paid little attention to
pay attention now about Hillary Clinton
take a look thirteen crimes she
committed and we got up to about
eighteen I'm sorry Hillary
I know you're very disappointing you to
win but you're a criminal
equal justice would mean you should go
to jail the the I do not know why the
Justice Department is not investigating
you equal justice would be in Hilary
goes to jail now Giuliani also took on
the disgraced former FBI director James
Comey let's watch this you have an
investigation in which Muller is
selected the day after he's turned down
for FBI director why Rosenstein who was
there when Muller was turned down there
are thousands of people that could have
been selected for that job also a friend
of James Comey and James Comey seems to
be they're there they're there their
core of their investigation he's telling
the truth the president is it I know
James Comey I know the president sorry
Jim you're a liar a disgraceful liar
every FBI agent in America has his head
down because of you a disgraceful liar
now the former mayor also slammed the
FBI's handling of the Michael Kohn
investigation take a look at this
$130,000 payment right a settlement
payment which is a very regular thing
for lawyers to do the question there was
the only possible violation there would
be was it a campaign finance violation
but usually were result in a fine by the
way not just big storm storm troopers
coming in and breaking down his
apartment and breaking out his office
alright let's take a step back if you
can believe it all the news we just laid
out for you all those crucial
developments that you just watched that
we aired last night live on this program
were largely ignored by the abusively
biased news media in this country
instead for 24 hours these lazy these
abusively biased echo-chamber people and
the fake news overpaid media have been
erupting over only one 30-second clip
again and again and again
take a look having something to do with
paying some stormy Daniels woman 130,000
I mean which is gonna turn out to be
perfectly legal that money was not
campaign money sorry I'm giving you a
fact
that you don't know it's not campaign
money no campaign finance violation so
they funneled it through the law firm
funnel throw law firm and the president
repaid it now as usual the media's
analysis their interpretation is all
wrong now this doesn't change the fact
that President Trump did not initially
know about the payment or that the
purpose with the payment that he didn't
know initially until a long time after
the transaction took place it doesn't
change the fact that Michael Kohn took
this action to benefit the company that
he served as vice president and attorney
for now let's help the media follow the
bouncing ball pay close attention so he
can keep up now in January the Wall
Street Journal they first reported about
the Cohn payment to stormy Daniels which
we know happened in October before the
election then in February in an
interview with the New York Times
Michael Kohn denied that neither the
Trump campaign nor the Trump
Organization had reimbursed him meaning
Michael Kony it said he uses old money
clearly leaving open the possibility
that the President himself then
president-elect at the time might have
reimbursed him from personal funds now
on April 1st President Trump while he
said this aboard Air Force One take a
look
and I meant when he's president now the
president he obviously knew about the
story at this time it had been so widely
reported since January what are you
saying is he didn't know about the
payment prior to the story being covered
now of course this did not stop the
mainstream media and their hysteria from
reaching yet another fever pitch like
the Russia Russia Russia story that they
have no evidence on take a look good
evening Rachel and I have to confess I
did not watch all of your show tonight
because Rudy Giuliani went on the other
Network went on Fox News and he stayed
on longer than he should have because
that's when he got to the stormy Daniels
admission which is gigantic which is
Blockbuster and I thought he could be
someone out there publicly defending the
president and also someone who would
take a harder line when it came to the
Muller investigation but he seems to
have just created another mess there
seems to be a basic assumption that Rudy
Giuliani had a strategy of some sort at
all and I just remain unconvinced at
this point that that's the case if Rudy
Giuliani had been let's say counsel for
IBM and delivered a performance that
undercut IBM like he did last night for
the president states he'd be fired the
next morning in many ways you know the
hero of 9/11 is almost being forgotten
he's a severely stabbed damaged his
legacy what do you make of Giuliana's
legal strategy here well I liken it to a
murder-suicide he met metaphorically
murdered the president and and committed
suicide with respect to his own
reputation a 24-hour non-stop coverage
was so constant so obsessive so
outrageous well it's actually almost
funny except it's too serious but take a
look we'll begin with that stunning
revelation from president Trump's
attorney Rudy Giuliani last night
telling Fox News that Trump reimbursed
his fixer Michael Cohen dude this was a
stunning admission that Giuliani
overnight says was approved by his boss
the president offering
really contradictory account about that
payment too stormy Daniels after saying
he did not know anything about the hush
money payments to an adult film actress
who said they had sex now he says he
reimbursed his lawyer for making those
payments startling admission by Rudy
Giuliani leaves president Trump facing
new legal questions this morning about
whether he knew it about an attempt to
silence stormy Daniels how many times
have I said journalism in America is
dead it's almost unbelievable but it's
all too predictable the media just
cannot stop playing this show
meaning Hannity and the interviews that
we conduct it seems like they're
featuring me more than their own hosts
now I'm beginning to think at this point
maybe I need to start collecting a
paycheck from ABC CBS NBC fake new CNN
and the conspiracy theory Network MSNBC
and you know what because I'm providing
the real news that they rarely make on
their own now let's turn to even more
fake news earlier today and this is
serious NBC broke a big story a serious
story about Michael Kohn okay according
to the original report Cohen had been
wiretap weeks before the FBI raided his
home in office and his hotel room and
there was even more damning developments
from NBC News take a look at their
report this wiretap occurred several
weeks before the now public search
warrant that was executed here in New
York several weeks ago in addition to
that we've learned that at least one
phone call conversation between a line
belonging to Michael Cohen and the White
House was also intercepted we know from
court papers federal prosecutors have
already said that they conducted covert
surveillance of Michael Cohen's emails
leading up to the search warrant being
executed so this is a lot more than just
knocking on the door and asking for some
documents and now we're learning that a
major component of this report was once
again fake news now NBC was forced to
issue a quote correction that reads in
part quote three senior US officials now
dispute the wiretapping saying that the
modern monitoring of Cohn's phones was
limited to a log of calls known as a pen
register not a wiretap where
investigators can actually listen to the
calls yet again fake news from NBC now
while the media is busy reporting all
the
fake news about michael conan spinning
in circles over a small tiny portion of
my 40-minute interview with rudy
giuliani well we have actual news about
the lives of three of our fellow
Americans long held hostage by North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un the Lord's
little rocket man president Trump is
currently working on their release and
is hinting of some very hopeful news on
Twitter he wrote as everybody's aware
the past administration has long been
asking for three hostages to be released
from a North Korean labor camp but to no
avail
stay tuned now this is just one new
positive development from the Korean
Peninsula that is seeing now tremendous
progress under our new president now
let's break this down three American
lives are at stake your mainstream media
is yawning paying very little attention
Kim jong-un is making unprecedented
concessions the mainstream media is
yawning we're talking about
denuclearization of the entire Korean
Peninsula we have historically low
unemployment now in 14 states record
lows the media yawns Americans receiving
unemployment is the lowest since 1973
the media could care less
african-american unemployment Hispanic
unemployment women in the workforce
unemployment 17 year lows record lows
the media could care less do you need
any more proof that the news media in
this country does not care about the
truth about doing their job about you
they care about their liberal left-wing
pathetic agenda and they're like one big
huge massive echo chamber with a bunch
of overpaid spoiled brat anchors that
don't do their job